bonjour aujourd'hui j'ai envie de faire
plein de choses extraordinaires
lui est là bonjour julie bonjour kazim
est trop gentil fait un peu moins de
bruit s'il te plaît mais enfin pourquoi
vous j'ai compris mademoiselle futaie
dans le petit bois et tu as peur qu'un
si elle m'entend elles viennent embêter
mais pas du tout je n'ai pas vu
d'aujourd'hui et je me repose un peu
comment tu te reposes alors que moi je
viens de me lever
mais tant pis pour toi tu avais 4 lever
plus tôt tu m'aurais aider à ranger mon
casque je serai moins fatiguant
bon tu vraiment pas drôle pour moi je
vais voir en fois très bonne idée
france soir au casimiro que tu pourrais
pas créer un petit peu moins fort s'il
te plait je ne trie pas ou fat
alors s'il te plait je suis chaud tu es
un petit peu moins forts jugé très
fatigué fatigué c'est quand même pas en
nettoyant des ballons bon ben qu'oui de
casimir si je veux tout savoir ce matin
j'ai dû me lever très tôt afin d'étudier
voilà touama enfin alors moi je suis en
pleine forme et prêt à rendre service à
tout le monde
vous êtes tous les deux est utilisé pour
tout le monde mademoiselle je le facteur
c'est vous qui avez commandé ces bonbons
je pense oui oui poser le coq et la sig
des facteurs je la compare à bloquer ce
que tout à l'heure je me repose un peu
fort dont nous avions de la chance
moi aussi je suis fatigué seulement je
n'ai pas le temps de me reposer
vous avez peut-être trop travailler vous
aussi abba parlons-en casimir c'est
l'info de ton cousin théodule quoi mon
cousin théodule enfin beaucoup
d'interdits il ya deux jours qu'il a
quitté lille justement et il est parti
en emportant une liste d'objets commandé
par tous les gens de l'île aux enfants
et au lieu de renvoyer un colis à chacun
il a tout mis dans le même et à mon nom
le résultat il faut que je trouve moi
même le destinataire de chaque colis et
que je le lui porte
bref cc c'est quoi un destinataire
enfin que j'aimais en destinataire
celui qui est qui qui attend les colis
auquel est destiné un colis tandis que
l'expéditeur vois tu sais celui qui
expédie un colis qui envoie un colis
voilà tu vois kazimierz ce paquet j'en
suis le destinataire voilà oui par
exemple un autre destinataire au mont
bart eeckhout et ça va j'ai compris je
ne suis quand même pas complètement
idiot rabreau ombre pardonne-moi casimir
ait pu toucher
j'ai pas le temps plus chaud alors voilà
je vais arranger ça puisque c'est mon
cousin théodule qui a fait une bêtise il
est normal que ce soit moi casimir son
cousin il a réparé vraiment casimir mais
comment peux tu mets des toits et bien
vous allez apporter ici tous les colis
et puis j'irai distribué à chaque à
chaque destinataire le frein au dessus
tu ferais c'est pour fuir
casimir à puisque tu es prêt à me rendre
service je veux bien que tu te moques un
petit peu de moi
bon alors tu m' attends je reviens je
vais aller chercher le colis a tout de
suite d'accords bon moi je vais
commencer à préparer mon stand
j'appellerai mon entreprise
les messageries casimir
[Musique]
citons kazemi remettons stands et déjà
terminée ouais tu as vu c'est beau hein
messagerie casimir ses superbes genestin
à tokyo voici les objets le carton ici
facteur là voilà voilà voilà bah tu me
rend fier c'est avec factor vous pouvez
compter sur moi
bon elle vient casimir je te remercie à
demain et bon courage bonne journée
facteurs au braqueur en série je sors
les objets fini de vider le carton
j'accroche la liste voilà un instant
dont casimir comment feras tu pour
savoir à qui dois porter tous ces objets
enfin c'est vraiment très facile un très
facile je vais regarder les métiers de
chacun des destinataires
ah oui et puis je prendrai un un objet
risque
et puis j'ai envie et puis bon bah je
crois que tu as raison phrase qui
n'arrivera jamais tout seul dont casimir
si j'appelais les enfants pour t d un
robot oui ça c'est une idée parce
enfants venez vivre une vie tu quelqu'un
a besoin de votre aide
chacune des personnes inscrites sur
cette liste a commandé un de ces objets
et casimir doigt les leur portée mais
qu'un petit peu perdues bah oui regardez
oui moi l'aller les métiers n'est ce pas
il ya un objet qui appartient à un
soudeur un autre un électricien un agent
de police une infirmière un jardinier un
homme grenouille menuisier et un skieur
on y va gagner ben oui premier objet
ça c'est un bâton de ski c'est donc pour
esquire dire casimir d'accord ça c'est
pour l'homme grenouille parce que c'est
une palme une des deux palmes construit
au pied pour avancer sous l'eau pas
d'accord ton blanc pour faire la
circulation pour un agent de police qui
a quasiment un bac kan d'agents de
police
ceci est oui c'est un petit râteau c'est
donc pour un jardinier tient quasiment
20 tout le jardinier avancer c'est pour
une infirmière qu'est ce que c'est c'est
une seringue avec l'aiguillé où il
s'applique quand je me rase atteint son
but ses voiles à la fois qu'elles auront
été un petit peu dangereux ceci parce
qu'elle est une prise multiple payé en
branche ici et on branche qui s'y tient
casimir pas pour l'électricité si c'est
pour le soudeur qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un chalumeau ou pire gazinière un
chalumeau
ça appartient aux soudeurs ou un très
très bel objet
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un rabot pour
le menuisier un rabot de menuisier bon
bain et bien moi la cuisine les enfants
grâce à vous je saurai qu à qui remettre
ces objets intelligents françois qui
sait je vais te dire une chose rires ce
jeu m'a vraiment fatigué à l'endiguer
oui tiens je souhaiterais que tu prennes
tous ces objets oui et comme toi tu t'es
reposer quand tu es en pleine forme que
tu les porte voix même au destinataire
salue les énergies
mais qu'est ce qui marche ou pas mais
mais mais je suis coincé